,
THE POLITICS OF DIVISION, IT'S
CRITICAL FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR QUEST FOR POWER.
HERE WITH REACTION FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP ALONG
WITH FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JOE CONCHA, LET'S START YOUR
REACTION TO SENATOR TIM SCOTT
WHICH I FOUND REPULSIVE.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
SOME OF THE COMMENTARY YOU HEARD
THERE IS IN AND OF ITSELF
RACIST.
HOW ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY CHOSE TIM SCOTT
TO DELIVER THIS MESSAGE BECAUSE
HE WAS WELL-EQUIPPED TO DO SO.
HE'S AN INTELLIGENT INDIVIDUAL,
WELL RESPECTED SENATOR WITHIN
OUR PARTY, OF COURSE THEY DEFER
IMMEDIATELY TO RACE BECAUSE THAT
IS ALL THEY KNOW.
JOE BIDEN, IF YOU SAY YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THIS IS A RACIST
COUNTRY, THEN I GUESS WILL NOT
BE HEARING YOU CONDEMNING BLACK
LIVES MATTER, I GUESS YOU'RE
GOING TO COME OUT AND SAY YOU
KNOW LONGER BELIEVE IN CRITICAL
RACE THEORY BEING TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOL 1619 PROJECT.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY TEACHES OUR
PEOPLE AND OUR CHILDREN TO JUDGE
ONE ANOTHER NOT BASED ON THE
CONTENT THEIR CHARACTER BUT
SOLELY ON THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN.
GROWING UP IN HATING THIS
COUNTRY AND HATING ONE ANOTHER
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT LOOK ALIKE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING BUT
THIS IS AGAIN PART OF WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS DO.
THEY ALWAYS TURN WHAT THEY ARE
DOING AND THEY TRY TO SAY
REPUBLICANS ARE DOING IT, WHAT A
DISGUSTING DISPLAY THAT WAS.
>> Sean: I'VE COMPLIMENTED YOU
BEFORE, I THINK YOU ARE PROBABLY
THE BEST INFORMED STUDENT AND
COLUMNIST ON THE MEDIA, YOU
DESERVE YOUR OWN MEDIA SHOW ON
FOX, YOU DID SUCH A GOOD JOB.
YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE MEDIA
ALL THESE YEARS, HAVE YOU EVER
SEEN ANYTHING QUITE THIS BAD?
IN THIS DAY AND AGE OF
CANCEL CULTURE, WOKE AMERICA
THAT YOU CAN SAY THE THINGS THAT
WERE SAID ABOUT SENATOR SCOTT?
>> THANKS FOR THE KIND WORDS,
CLEARLY YOU HAVE VENMO AND YOU
GOT THAT PAYMENT I SENT YOU
EARLIER.
I DON'T TAKE COMPLIMENTS WELL,
I'M SORRY.
I WANT TO GO TO THAT THE BIDEN
INTERVIEW AND I'LL ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION BY JUST GIVING A SMALL
EXAMPLE AS FAR AS WHAT WE SAW
WITH HIM ON NBC.
HOW TO PUSH BACK WHEN THE
PRESIDENT MAKES SUCH A
RIDICULOUS CLAIM.
BIDEN SAID IF HE WAS CLOSER THAN
6 FEET DURING THAT INTERVIEW, HE
WOULD PUT HIS MASK BACK ON.
I WOULD SAY OKAY, YOU'RE
VACCINATED, CORRECT?
UNVACCINATED, RIGHT?
THE VACCINES WORK, RIGHT?
YES.
WHY DO YOU HAVE TO PUT A MASK
BACK ON IF ALL OF THOSE THINGS
ARE TRUE?
I WANT TO HEAR THE PRESIDENT
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BECAUSE WE
SOUGHT DURING THE JOINT SESSION
OF CONGRESS WHERE YOU HAVE THE
PRESIDENT WALK IN WITH A MASK
ON, GET TO THE PODIUM AND TAKE A
MASK OFF AND EVERYBODY ELSE
INCLUDING THE HOUSE SPEAKER AND
THE VICE PRESIDENT BEHIND HIM
ARE BOTH WEARING MASKS DESPITE
EVERYBODY BEING VACCINATED.
WHAT YOU'RE NOT SEEING IN MEDIA
REPORTS IS VACCINATIONS WHILE
THEY WERE GOING UP FOR MONTHS,
RISING STEADILY IN THE PAST TWO
WEEKS WE ARE SEEING A DROP NOW
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS OF
VACCINATIONS THAT ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED AND I WONDER IF
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE OPTICS YOU
ARE SEEING ON THE SCREEN WHERE
LAWMAKERS WHO SWEAR THE VACCINE
WORK SINCE WHERE THEY SHOULD GO
OUT AND GET IT CONTINUE TO WEAR
MASKS.
TO YOUR POINT EARLIER, THE CDC
SAYS IT'S PERFECTLY SAFE AND
INDOOR SETTINGS IF EVERYBODY IS
VACCINATED -- OPTICS MATTER AND
THIS PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE AND DO GE